Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters and we're going to be talking about the heart rate variability test that we do in our office.
Why we do it? What we look for, what it could help indicate, and how we could make corrections to help our bodies heal better through that testing. So let's get going.
So as we look at our tests that we do, it comes back with a printout like this. And really this center part of the graph is what we're looking at. This is the balance for your sympathetic and your parasympathetic nervous system.
So as I tell people, you have to kind of remember back to high school biology and what those two things are.
You have a voluntary nervous system like moving your arms and your legs and you have an involuntary nervous system or something that's relatively involuntary.
You don't have a lot of volitional control over your heart rate and your liver function.
You don't have to think about digestion, digestion, split, make red blood cells. You don't even feel that anything exists. These things are done automatically.
So think of your automatic nervous system as that's what's your autonomic nervous system. It's separated into two components, your sympathetics and your parasympathetics.
Kind of confusing, but they're two kind of opposing systems. Your sympathetics are your fight or flight response on this graph. This is what we see right here.
This is a bar graph. So this blue is the height of the sympathetic response in this sample person.
This is the parasympathetic. The parasympathetic in this person is a little more dominant.
That's what we'd really want to see in a patient that is struggling with a chronic illness. We'd want to see a more dominant parasympathetic nervous system in general.
But we tend to say that we want them in the middle and balanced in this green middle zone that would be a normal response.
Your sympathetic nervous system controls your fight or flight response. Everybody has experienced this. You have a police car pull up in front of you or behind you with the lights on and you feel a sympathetic response.
Immediately when you see them in the rear view mirror with the lights on are you hear the lights. You get a little flustered. Your heart rate goes through the roof.
Your blood pressure goes up. You get a little clammy. Your eyes dilate. Blood shunts to your stability for you to run away from this crisis situation.
In that case, in that immediate instance, you would get a sympathetic response. It would heighten this response. It would spike the sympathetic.
That's what it's supposed to do. That's how you deal with a crisis.
The polar bear jumped out in front of you. You need a sympathetic nervous system to kick in order for you to be able to access the amount of adrenal flow and ATP production for you to run away from that polar bear.
You can do these superhuman things in the middle of a sympathetic response, but we don't want to live there. The parasympathetic response controls all the things that you want to be happening if you're dealing with a chronic disease.
It controls your digestion. It controls your detoxification pathways. It controls your ability to make red blood cells. Your ability to make white blood cells. It's your immune function.
Really, when we're fighting a chronic disease, we'd really most diseases. We'd like to be a little parasympathetic dominant. This little diagram illustrates that.
When your sympathetic kick in, your eyes dilate. You get a little cotton mouth. Your bronchial tombs dilate to get oxygen to your tissues really quick.
It inhibits digestion because, hey, we don't eat digest food. We're going to get eaten by a polar bear.
It stimulates breakdown of glucose glycogen stores in the liver to glucose so you have readily accessible energy production by yourselves, by your muscle cells, particularly in your heart rate increasing so that you can run away from this polar bear.
It stimulates epinephrine or epinephrine release by your adrenal glands. It's a cortisol response in itself by your adrenal glands.
It's going to do all sorts of other things. Your parasympathetic reaction on the other hand is going to constrict your pupil. It's going to cause excess cell evasion.
So you're going to have more saliva in your mouth because it's getting ready for digestion. And saliva controls has talented there to help digest carbohydrates.
It's going to slow your heart rate. So this is what slows down your heart rate decreases the contractility of your heart.
You get some break your bronchial constriction because we don't eat, we're not running away from a polar bear.
You're worried about digested food. You're worried about detoxification in the liver. You're worried about sexual function and reproduction.
You're worried about immune system population and destruction of pathogens.
So we need this to deal with somebody who has cancer. We don't want a hyper-sympathetic response.
So we look at a graph like this. This would be good if it was a cancer patient of mine. If it was reversed and sympathetic was way up here and parasympathetic was way down here, that would be something we don't want to see.
So some of the abnormal findings on this test would be, well, worst would be they're both way down here. That means that part of the nervous system is basically shutting down.
We don't see that very often. We don't want to see that at all.
Another abnormal finding would be what I stated a hyper-sympathetic response. That's very common.
People are stuck in a hyper-sympathetic response. They're stuck in a sympathetic dominance.
And another one that we see a lot with live patients and anybody that has inflammation in the brain and it'll explain why.
As you see, both of these are through the rough. Both of them are capped out.
The graph here would show these two green things way out here. It's literally capped out the sympathetic and the parasympathetic are firing an overdrive.
Now there's only a few reasons why that would happen. Let me not to get too dirty on you, but let's explain that from a neurological perspective.
So this is a cross section of a person's brain. This is the front of your head. This is your forehead right here.
This is going down your spine right here. This is the back of your head here. Your occipital lobe that controls all your vision.
Your frontal lobe, which makes you really human, controls your thought, reasoning, center, where you make decisions and such.
You're providing a lobe where you have your sensory function in a cutaway, the cutaway here and behind this piece here is your temporal lobe, which houses memory and hearing a lot of other things too.
So we really want to concentrate on the frontal lobe here because it's communication to these deep parts of the brain.
This is what's called your archaeocortex here is what we're talking about when we're dealing with the sympathetic and the parasympathetic.
So the sympathetic and the parasympathetics are part of what would be called your older nervous system where the cortex is a newer, newer part of your nervous system.
We need many animals don't have cortex and neocortex here. They only have what's called the archaeocortex or the reptilian brain here.
So this would be, you could say your instinctual brain, you don't think about what's going on with your mesencephalon, this part right here, right here, and your puns.
You don't think about those, but the puns is where the parasympathetics come from, the mesencephalon is where the sympathetic come from, right there.
So the sympathetic and the parasympathetics are part of that archaeocortex that instinctual brain and how your instinctual brain is controlled by the neocortex is through the frontal lobe here.
I say all this because it's important, but we look at a person's autonomics and if they're both through the roof or if just the sympathetic are very high, we have to go back to neurology.
It's a little confusing, let me talk through this, your frontal lobes communication to both the sympathetic in the mesencephalon and the parasympathetics in the puns is inhibitory, meaning that your prefrontal lobe,
your frontal cortex, without your knowledge even, so it's not volitional, fires neurons back to the mesencephalon and neurons back to the puns that inhibit it.
So think of the frontal lobe as the executive of the brain or the parent of the brain and the midbrain here, the archaeocortex is like a naughty teenager.
It always just wants to fire, it always just wants to do what it wants to do, and it's without the parent saying you can't do that, calm down, settle down, sit your seat, be quiet, this just acts out.
So when I have a decrease in my communication or my frontal lobe to my midbrain, I'm going to have a graph where both of these are sky high.
If I solely have a decrease in my communication to my mesencephalon, I'm going to have a graph where just my sympathetic are high.
So from a neurological component, my sympathetic can ride high because of lack of inhibition from my frontal lobe to where the sympathetic are housed, which is the mesencephalon.
Follow me. So from a neurological perspective, if we see on the graph that the person has either one or both of those that are really high through the roof, we want to look at, is there a source of inflammation that's blocking that communication?
Is there an issue with the frontal lobe that it's not communicating to the mesencephalon or the puns?
And we see that there's a lot with people with Lyme disease or a person that has brain cancer or a person that has any sort of inflammation due to toxicity due to something that's going on in the brain, inflammation of the brain is going to decrease by frontal lobe's communication to the midbrain.
It is going to have these guys packed out in a hyperfunction because that's what they would do if they didn't have the inhibition from the frontal lobe.
So lack of frontal lobe inhibition to the sympathetic will cause the sympathetic to go sky high, lack of frontal lobe inhibition to both of them will cause both of them to go sky high.
Now in my other videos, I talk about the neurotransmitters that are involved with that and this is important too. So as we look at somebody's genetics, they could have genetic defects on specific genes that could cause excitatory neurotransmitters to stay in the brain for a long period of time and not and actually you can make more excitatory neurotransmitters that you're supposed to.
And that could be a piece of this too, but right now we're talking about the neurology. So the neurotransmitter that we're talking about in this is typically glutamate.
So watch some of the videos on glutamate and glutamate and that's why we don't want people that have brain cancer to be eating a lot of glutamate because it converts to glutamate and causes this to ramp up and causes inflammation in the brain, but that's another topic altogether.
So the neurology is the frontal lobe is supposed to inhibit the midbrain and when it doesn't inhibit the midbrain, we have abnormal findings here.
So there are some exercises that we've created. These are just functional neurology exercises that could help with these.
So if I have a hyper-sympathetic state, I know that I have a hyper-bessencephalon. So I applied these high-firing bessencephalic therapy.
So I could easily said that this is for a hyper-sympathetic state, same thing.
So here's some specific exercises that we could do with that. And I'm not going to go through these on this video altogether.
So if you're a patient of ours and you have your tests that we did on you, you have hyper-sympathetic or both of them, we would give you a handout like this that I would have you start doing.
So remember, this thing right here, hyper-sympathetic state is going to dilate your pupils.
So if we wear sunglasses, that's going to help calm the bessencephalon down.
And it's been found that certain colored sunglasses could actually be more appropriate.
It's rose colored, amber colored, even with some people a light violet or purplish color to the sunglasses can be very soothing to calm the bessencephalon.
So what kind of symptoms would a person be having if they're stuck in a hyper-sympathetic state? They might be extremely anxious, have a lot of anxiety in their body.
They can't calm that down. They're stuck in a hyper-bessencephalic state.
They've done a pair of rose colored glasses or amber colored glasses or yellowish or purplish glasses.
And they go, wow, this just makes me feel so much calm. It can be very beneficial.
From a straight neurology perspective, place in a cotton ball or a one of those foam things that block hearing in your right ear could calm the bessencephalon.
The foul smell or what you consider a foul smell in your right nostril so you close your left nostril and just breathe it in the right nostril could calm the bessencephalon.
This is just a straight neurology.
Slow, deep belly breathing, playing mammary games, that's a frontal lobe stimulation.
Doing things like the chi machine, which helps move lymph but it stimulates the cerebellum, which inversely stimulates the frontal lobe, which could calm the bessencephalon.
Bibration therapy works on the same pathway. You can calm the bessencephalon.
Watching glutamate levels, we talked about that briefly. That's the neurotransmitter that we're looking at.
Looking at inflammation with inflammatory foods. So lots of times you see with the dairy issues, causes inflammation of the brain.
If it affects that communication between the frontal lobe and the mid-brain can cause a high-riding bessencephalon and you can go into a sympathetic dominant state.
So these are some exercises that you could do.
Exercises to stimulate the vagal nerve. So for in a state where we see a lot of patients that they have a hyper-sympathetic and a very low parasympathetic, they're going to have a very hard time fighting off cancer or something like that.
That's what we want to stimulate the parasympathetics.
So what are the key things to do to stimulate the parasympathetics? Where can we access that?
So the vagal nerve or cranial nerve, Ted is your main parasympathetic pathway.
Gargoline, stimulated a gag reflex, hummed, loudly, sagged, constimulated parasympathetic reaction.
This is one of the key components that we use especially with cancer patients to stimulate a parasympathetic response.
That is doing coffee or probiotic animals.
Now you might have heard that coffee animals are really good for your liver, they detox your liver.
Yes, but maybe one of the most beneficial things about a coffee animal is it stimulates the parasympathetic system through almost direct stimulation of the vagal nerve in the rectal area.
So these are some things that we'd want to do to calm down and to control the autonomics because the autonomics control all your organ function.
You don't even have to know that you have a liver, it's controlled by your autonomic nervous system.
So if we could get a better handle on the autonomics, we could measure it, we could make sure that we're going to handle on it, we could give our body a better chance to heal.
All right, look at some of the other videos that I have on glutamate and glutamine and how that affects your brain and the autonomics and cancer and such.
As well as anxiety and things, I hope this video helped and we will talk very soon.